>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sarah Browning: Hey,
everybody [laughs].
You've got to look at yourselves.
You are one beautiful crowd.
Welcome to the fourth annual
National Book Festival Teen
Poetry Slam.
My name is Sarah Browning.
I have the great incredible
privilege of being the cofounder
and executive director
of Split This Rock.
We are so proud to cosponsor this
slam with the Library of Congress
and the National Endowment
for the Arts, and to be here
on this beautiful, cold, rainy
September 2nd with all of you.
And with remarkable teen poets
from the Washington, D.C. area,
from Baton Rouge, from Minneapolis,
and from Portland, Oregon.
Let's give it up.
Right on. I want to give a shout
out to our ASL interpreters.
Yeah. I think they've
been working hard all day.
Am I right?
Yes. And you know what?
Poetry is not easy to interpret.
No. It's not.
No. And especially these teen
poets because they have to keep
in a time limit, and so
sometimes they talk very fast.
Yeah. So we're going to be
shouting them out all evening.
So huge thank you for their
hard work and dedication.
That's right.
And a thank you to the
National Book Festival
for always having interpretation
and other access
for people with disabilities.
Right on. So I'm going
to take a second
to tell you about Split This Rock.
We are a national organization
based here in Washington,
D.C. Our mission is to cultivate,
teach, and celebrate poetry
that bears witness to injustice
and provokes social change.
You think we need some
of that poetry right now?
I think we do.
You think we've been needing that
poetry for the last 400 years?
I think we have.
We've been having that poetry
too in the United States
and throughout the world,
throughout all of human history.
And it's Split This Rock's mission
to elevate those voices, young,
older, our forbearers, and our
current brilliant practitioners
at all levels of their
careers, of their writing lives.
And we are just incredibly moved by
the poetry that is being written,
performed, published in America
and throughout the world today.
Split This Rock is proud to
present that poetry and to foster it
in many programs nationally and
throughout the Washington D.C. area.
Our cornerstone programs
are a biannual,
that means every two years, biannual
-- We always get that wrong.
Poetry festival.
Split This Rock poetry festival.
Poems of provocation and witness.
You're all invited.
The next one is April
19th to the 21st, 2018.
You have time to plan
for those dates.
You better be there.
I invite you to visit the
table at the back where Sue
and Ruben are sitting
there to welcome you.
They're waving at you.
They're beautiful.
There they are.
And you can sign up for the
listserv there or you can visit us
on Instagram, Twitter,
and the Facebook.
And sign up to get not only
updates about programs,
including Split This Rock Poetry
Festival coming up April 19th
to the 21st, 2018, but also
every week Split This Rock poem
of the week because it's --
We're creative like that.
We're poets.
It's called Split This
Rock Poem of the Week.
And it will come to you in
your inbox or on social media,
a poem by a contemporary
poet reflecting
on the pressing social
issues of today.
In all kinds of different ways.
And it comes to you
on Friday morning.
You might be a government
functionary.
Any of those in this room?
Yeah. Yeah.
You might be a teacher.
You might be a religious leader.
You might just be somebody
whose heart is hurting.
We got any of those
folks in the room today?
Yeah. And maybe you need a little
bit of poetry in your life.
So sign up for that
poem of the week.
You won't be sorry.
Our other signature program is a
youth program, and you're going
to see that highlighted today.
We've got after school poetry clubs
in high schools throughout
the D.C. area.
We're the home of the
D.C. Youth Slam Team.
Three stars.
Hey. That's a thing.
They do it.
Yeah. And open mics at Busboys
and Poets, two locations,
5th and K in Shirlington, Virginia.
And check us all out at
splitthisrock.org for more.
All right, then.
And I just want to ask you all,
I want to ask you all,
to support young voices.
This is the future.
This is the future
not just of poetry,
not just of this country,
but of our Earth.
The voices you're about to hear.
And we need to invest and
support these young people
and the great variety, the
great richness, of youth voices
that you're about to hear tonight.
So thank you for being here.
And with that said, it's
my very great pleasure
to introduce your MC tonight,
our Split This Rock's
youth program coordinator.
You've already seen him once.
I give you my colleague,
my friend, Joseph Green.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Which one?
I think that each one
of these mics calls
for a different type of speaking.
This is my spoken word.
Hey, everybody.
How you doing tonight?
Make some noise.
This is my Barack.
It's going to be a good evening.
Poetry. Poetry.
Poetry. All right.
Cool. Just an idea I had.
Hi. My name is Joseph Green,
and I'm going to be your host.
Raise your hand if you've ever been
to a spoken word event,
slam, or open mic.
True. True.
True. All right.
Hands down.
Raise your hand if you've never
been to one of these events before.
Ooh. Welcome.
This is going to be
a good time for all.
But there's a caveat to that.
This is only going to be a good time
if you open yourself
up to that good time.
Right? We can be standing in
front of something prolific,
but if our minds are closed, there's
no way for that message to get in.
And there's so many things that get
in the way of that happening, right?
We see someone who
doesn't look like us.
We see someone and they say
something that we disagree with
or they come from a
place we don't come from
and all of a sudden we shut off.
On this stage today there are
going to be young people from all
over this country, all
shapes and sizes and colors
and sexual identities, and all of
that is going to be here on display
for you laid at the altar
of your consideration.
And it will make you a better person
if you open yourself up to it.
So if you're ready to have a good
time, I'm going to need you all
to make some real noise right now.
[ Applause ]
Good. Good.
It feels good.
So for those of you who have never
been to a poetry slam before,
I'm going to take you
through a couple of rules
so you understand what's
about to happen here tonight.
We have seven competitors
from all over the country
who have prepared poems,
original pieces,
that they will share with you.
Those poems have to
be within 3 minutes
with a 30 second grace period.
There's a first round
and a second round.
And the first round because
we are sponsoring this slam
with the Library of Congress
in honor of the Book Festival,
they have to read a poem that
is about reading or writing
or education or something
under that umbrella.
So they had to write new
poems just for this event.
Right? The second round can
be about anything they want.
So brace yourselves.
Okay. So a poetry slam is a
competition where you're going
to hear a poem, and we have
some very special people
in the audience today who are
in charge of judging the poetry.
Now we realize how silly that
is, the idea that we're going
to take something that is
subjective and objectify it.
But this is America [laughs]
and so we have found a way.
So they will hear this.
They will hear the poems.
A zero will be the worst
poem they have ever heard.
Simultaneously, all of us will fall
asleep and the slam will be over.
Right? Now a 10 is the best
poem they have ever heard.
Simultaneously, all of us
will be awoken and float
up to whatever is next for us.
That's it.
There's no more slam.
Nothing. We're good.
All right?
So when that happens you'll feel it.
You'll know.
All right.
And so these judges have
a very, very hard job.
Right? They have to take this
art and give numbers to it.
Audience, you also have a job.
This is a participatory sport.
Okay? So the judges
will give their scores.
Then I will call them out.
I will say, "7.5."
Your job at that point is to react
in whatever way you
think is appropriate.
If you feel that score
is accurate to the poet,
you will cheer and say, "Yay.
I believe that is a
very accurate score."
You have to say that every time.
No. If you do not agree with
the score, we don't boo here.
We say, "Listen to the poem."
Because maybe they missed it.
Right? They give it
a 6.5 and you are
about to transcend to another place.
Right? Maybe it didn't come in.
So you say, "Listen to the poem."
So I'm going to need
everyone to work with me.
I'm going to call out a score that
you disagree with, and I need you
to be loud and exuberant and
tell me what you're going to do.
All right.
Here we go.
4.5.
[ Audience Shouts ]
I'm sorry.
But it's going to be fine.
Now I'm going to introduce
you to our esteemed judges.
I'm going to go over
to my Barack mic.
So we have somebody else special
in the audience [inaudible] before.
All right.
So this is the Library of
Congress National Book Festival.
The Library of Congress has
a librarian of Congress.
And she is in the building tonight.
Please clap it up for
Ms. Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
You want to say something?
Come on and say something.
We got time.
>> Carla Hayden: Well, and
this always gets me all juiced
up because last year I got to
be a judge and it's hard work.
This is a rough crowd.
I got -- Didn't I get challenged?
>> Joseph Green: I
thought you did a good job.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, thank you.
>> Joseph Green: Yeah.
We're contractually
[inaudible] to say so.
No.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
Well, I just want to
tell you enjoy the --
I talked about this slam
for the rest of the year,
and it gave me inspiration.
And I just had to come and say
thank you all for being here.
Thank you for everybody that's going
to get up here and share with us.
>> Joseph Green: I appreciate that.
They appreciate that, young people.
[ Applause ]
Proud to live in a
world where things
like this are still important.
All right.
So now to your esteemed judges.
One of your first judges you may
or may not have heard of him.
His name is Juan Felipe Herrera.
And so each judge was asked
to give a little bit to say
about themselves, and this is
what he said about himself.
Recent poet laureate and for the
young people performing tonight I
believe in you.
Can we clap it up for
Juan Felipe Herrera?
Our next judge goes by the
name of Elizabeth Acevedo.
Now here's what's funny about that.
Not everybody in the room clapped
because everyone don't
know Elizabeth yet,
but I'm going to tell you
some things about Elizabeth
because next year everybody in
this room is going to be clapping.
It goes like this.
She's a National Poetry
Slam champion.
Her debut YA novel "The Poet
X," out from HarperCollins,
will be out for sale March 2018.
Additionally, that festival
that Sarah was talking
about that happens every
two years next April?
She will be a featured
reader at that festival.
Can we please clap it up
for Elizabeth Acevedo?
And next we have Melissa de la Cruz.
Author of "The Disney
Descendents" and "Alex and Eliza,"
a novel about young Alexander
Hamilton and Elizabeth Schuyler
which let me tell you I
cannot wait to buy that book.
And important to know.
Do I look as good in light as I
did in the -- I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Just going to keep it going.
Also, she once came in third
in a slam of three people.
Can we please clap it up
for Melissa de la Cruz?
Our next judge, Adrian Matejka.
Clap. There you go.
He has a new book out,
"Map to the Stars."
One of the finals judges
for the Poetry
Out Loud competition this year,
and one of the most pleasant
individuals I've met here
at the book festival, please
clap it up for Adrian Matejka.
And last but not least,
his name is Joey Reisberg.
Clap it up for him now.
He is a rising senior at
Carver Center in Towson.
He is the 2016 National Poet for the
Northeast, and his favorite thing is
to see young people
with talent rise.
Clap it up.
Now back over here.
I'm going to read out
the names of the poets
who are performing tonight.
They -- What they -- If you come
from a city, what is that called?
They hail.
Thank you.
This is participatory.
If I ask a question,
just shout it out.
All right.
They hail from these cities.
Anybody in here from
Portland, Oregon?
That -- That didn't come
with one of the teams?
How about anybody here from
the Northwest of the country?
Make some noise.
Don't raise your hand.
High five.
All right.
So we also have a team
here from Baton Rouge.
Anybody here from that
part of the country?
Make some noise.
These two people are super excited
to be from that part of the country.
Welcome. All right.
We also have poets from Minneapolis.
Yes. Anybody here from
that part of the country?
Awesome. All right.
We also have poets from
D.C. Anybody here from D.C.?
All right.
I'm saying that to say this.
For the rest of the evening, we
are on team clap for everybody.
Right? That's the team
that we are representing.
So when you see somebody
coming to the stage,
you clap like the future
is coming to the stage.
And your clapping is reflective
of how bright you want
the future to be.
All right?
So I'm going to call out their
names, and that's the type
of energy I'm going to
need to hear right now.
We have Maya [assumed spelling],
Catherine [assumed spelling],
Taya [assumed spelling],
Anaya [assumed spelling],
Asher [assumed spelling],
Sophia, and [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
This is a yes or no question.
Are you ready for a poetry slam?
You only had two choices,
and you got it wrong.
So if you've never been to a poetry
slam before, there's something
that we do at the beginning.
It's called the sacrificial poet.
Not as gory as it sounds.
This poet's job is to
calibrate the judges,
to make sure that they are
ready for the performance.
This person is not
in the actual slam.
So they're not up to win.
But the score that the judges
give will be what they use
as their litmus for the
rest of the program.
So we typically have a poet just
like the rest of the poets who come
up and read an original poem.
Unfortunately, one of the poets from
Baton Rouge was unable to join us.
He has a heart condition
and is in --
on bed rest right now
and couldn't make it.
Her name is Jasmine Smith.
Can we give her a round of applause?
Because this is being filmed,
and her poetic spirit is
about to be felt in this room.
So reading one of Jasmine's
poems, the one that she created
for this space, a current member
of the D.C. Youth Slam Team,
three stars, hey, please
put your hands together
for Tyka [assumed spelling] Wallace.
[ Applause ]
>> Tyka Wallace: In
elementary school,
we were always given
secondhand books.
I knew this because
once I learned to read,
the stamps on the inside
cover read "Property
of Insert Wealthy School Name Here."
The pages were torn, and written on,
and I always wondered
what it would be like not
to receive a secondhand education.
If children are the future, the kids
at my elementary school
were learning
to take what they got,
to not protest too much.
To accept outdated information.
I guess a bunch of black kids
from Glen Oaks weren't
worthy of fresh prints.
When I got to high school, the
admission requirements got harder
which is to say the students got
whiter and the textbooks got newer.
Hot off the presses
with glossy covers.
When your school is black, volunteer
organizations will paint murals
to brighten up the
black neighborhoods.
When your school is
historically white,
you will have $1,000
gymnastics mats.
Somewhere across town a
white child is playing
on a brand new jungle gym
while a black student flips
through a book with missing pages.
White students receive iPads because
textbooks take too much maintenance.
Black kids tape pages together,
trying to piece their
history back together.
White kids get salad bars,
and we get another vending
machine filled with junk food.
They'd rather watch black
schools dissolve into ash,
rather watch them wash away,
than give them resources.
Rather spend $1 million
renovating the white school
than making sure there are
enough teachers at the black one.
When did separate, but equal
become part of the curriculum?
If we had accurate history books,
we could see that it
was never taken out.
We could see how ink smudges look a
lot like the blood of my ancestors
and how their pain is consolidated
into a civil rights chapter,
like they haven't been
surviving this entire time.
Like these books, my city is so
segregated you could divide it
in half which is as much math as
they teach us around here anyway.
They call my high school a castle
the way it towered over the city,
and maybe that's why it felt more
like a guarded tower for privilege
than a place of enrichment.
The school was built by people who
couldn't have walked its hallways,
and its whiteness is deafening.
Its resources are deafening.
Its classism is deafening.
If reading and writing
are so essential,
then how come they have written
us out of this narrative?
How come the right to a
decent education is property
of "Insert wealthy
school name here"?
When they rip a solid education
from black hands like ripping pages
out of a children's
book, it becomes clear
that we were not meant to learn.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: She was given that
assignment like 30 minutes ago.
Right? Judges, that is the longest
amount of time you will be given
to come up with your scores.
In fact, I am talking even longer
now to make sure that in 10 seconds
when I say, "Judges, show me
your scores," you are prepared.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Judges, show me your scores.
I tried. From low to high we have
a 7, a 7, a 7.3, a 7.4, and a 7.6.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
[ Applause ]
I am so happy that was
the first poem read.
For anybody in here
who was questioning,
"I wonder where this is going to
go," that's where it's going to go.
And I say this not as a warning,
because I don't care to warn you.
But in the hopes that this
work is received well.
If you have a feeling
when you hear some
of these poems like,
"That's not right."
Or, "That makes me feel weird."
Or like an allergy, right, stop.
Be mindful.
Ask yourself, "Why is that
the feeling I'm feeling?"
Could there be something
wrong in this world
that doesn't directly affect me?
Possibly. And how can we
make the world a better place
by caring for one another?
Right? Don't discount it because
it don't make sense to you
or doesn't happen in
your neighborhood.
That's why we're here in
this space, because you want
to bring these stories to
an entirely new audience.
We have poetry slams
all over the city.
We want you all to understand
that there are young people
on this planet that exist
outside of the realm
of what you see in the news.
Right? Or what you think
about when you go and you see
like whatever the new pop movie is.
There are people, young people,
who are considerate, who are aware,
who are awoke, still waking,
trying to wake the world.
Right? And a lot of
them are here tonight.
So please keep that in mind,
that this is not easy for them.
As confident as they will seem,
this is not easy for them.
As you would imagine,
any of you in front
of 1,000 people you've
never met before talking
about something particularly
personal.
All right.
So that's the level
we're going to set.
All right?
That's the type of
courage and bravery,
and that's what we need rewarded
when we bring the young
people on stage.
Now I have a simple
yes or no question.
Hint. The answer is yes.
Are you ready for a poetry slam?
Please put your hands together for
the first poet and the first round.
Maya.
[ Applause ]
>> Maya: Some kids come
to school wounds deep
as wells hidden beneath
Band-Aid stretched skin.
Teachers demand they try harder
to pull themselves apart,
to see how much more blood
they have left to give.
To sign an oath on the
top of their assignment.
Chubby cheeks and bright
eyes line the altar,
their thoughts more
profound than those
of philosophers they will
someday be assigned to read.
Their minds bustle with curiosity.
So why does schoolwork
look like human sacrifice?
Children sacrifice their creativity
for the system's convenience.
The system sacrifices children
for money, throws five year olds
on to assembly lines
that move too quickly,
not allowing them to
catch their breath.
Painting them with wide brush even
though there's only enough pigment
for a few bristles.
Letting the ones who never had
a chance fall through the cracks
and in to the locked doors
of the principal's office.
Reduce their cries for help
by calling it misbehavior.
Punish them with out
of school suspensions.
Convince them they're just
like criminals on house arrest.
Throw them in to the
cells of private prisons.
This will be easy when white people
in dark suits paint darker children
to look like dollar
signs in jumpsuits.
Skimp on their education
knowing it will lead to crime.
Do not teach them to read.
Stuff this poetry of 17th century
white men down their throats,
especially when they are choking.
Force them to analyze
someone else's words
so formulaically they
forget how to use their own.
Assign books so unrelatable
they never want
to read for pleasure again.
Do not teach them to write
with their own voice.
Tell them it is too informal.
Let them know that stories of truth
and trauma must be
packaged pretty enough
for the palatability
of their oppressors.
Value the stories of
slave owning presidents
and do not tell them their
country was built on graveyards
of stolen land and stolen breath.
Watch them fill in circles
as their minds grow numb
from stress and stimulants.
Blood pumping with Adderall
to replace the curiosity
that got bled out of them.
It is easy to do this when
they see learning as the enemy.
If somehow a child begin to emerge
from these ashes still curious,
still a fighter, still authentic,
tell their parents they
have a learning disorder.
Make them feel incompetent for
failing to turn in to Play-Doh
in the hands of a system that wants
them molded into perfect soldiers.
Tell them that they will
drown in this quicksand
and immediately throw
them a prescription pill.
Convince them it is
a life preserver.
Convince them this thing they do
for 40 hours a week is
a life preserver even
when they tell you
they don't know how
to preserve their own
happiness for the life of them.
Do not teach them their rights.
After all, it is your job to
sculpt kids to be prisoners
in jobs they will learn to hate.
In cycles of poverty they will
never have the tools to break.
In jail cells where you throw
away their ballot and chain them
to a world that will never change.
Call it democracy.
But when you see another
generation in shackles,
don't you dare call it freedom.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges.
Scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have a 6.9,
a 7.1, a 7.2, a 7.3, and a 7.9.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
[ Applause ]
So testing.
Check. 1. 2.
How's my mic sound?
My mic sounds nice.
Check. 1. Okay.
You're not ready.
All right.
So if you heard during
that first poem,
there were people who were snapping.
Right? Right?
If you hear a line that you
like, it's okay for you to snap.
Right? That way you can be like,
"Yo, I really like that poem,
but I'm not going to interrupt
it by walking up to the stage
and saying hey, I enjoyed
that line."
Right? So let's practice
that real quick.
Everybody snap.
Yes. I love doing that in
large crowds because I grew
up eating Rice Krispies and I
close my eyes and I remember.
You can also say, "Word."
Everybody say, "Word."
You can make that sound you make
when you have a delicious
piece of chocolate.
Didn't even have to tell you.
And, last but not least, you
can do something that I really
like invented by a friend
of mine [inaudible].
You can take the word she and
you can take the word Jesus
and no matter your
religious affiliation,
you can smash them together.
If you hear something that makes
you feel particularly holy,
you say, "Shesus."
It feels better when you participate
so I'm going to need everybody
in this room to give me their
best shesus on the count of three.
1. 2. 3. Doesn't it feel
good to participate?
If you're ready for your
next poet, say yeah.
Coming up next to the stage,
please put your hands
together for Catherine.
[ Applause ]
>> Catherine: According
to my journal,
I'm having more good days than bad.
A tiny heart on the cover corner,
a page for each day written
in at night with the
easiest key in the world.
Yellow is for happiness, pink
good, purple survivable, green sad.
Blue days, blue days are bad.
A childish word for how
I feel when I don't get
out of bed, but I want to.
To clean up my room and uncover the
scraps of yellow paper on my floor,
fold pink blankets, wear
my favorite purple socks.
Bad as if bad even comes close
to how I feel right then.
Bad as if I feel anything bad.
Like it only took 10 minutes for a
doctor to prescribe me something,
and bad like it's not working.
According to my journal, yellow
doesn't show up that much,
but there's lots of pink, the color
of smoothies I've started drinking
and my new sheets, of my best
friend's nails and sister's cheeks.
According to my journal,
I'm getting better.
According to my therapist,
I'm a lovely child.
You're welcome, mom.
According to her, I'm eating again.
According to me, yellow is for days
when I lean against my best friend
in history, when the sunset
was at 6:51 instead of 4,
when my brother knocks on my
door just to say he loves me.
Yellow is for days when I'm
convinced I've been faking it all
these years.
Yellow like my skin after
another day of not eating.
Like the honeysuckle candle I
bought to remind me of summer wind.
Yellow like the painting
in my kitchen.
The one my grandma owned.
February 13, 2012 I wore a
yellow shirt to school, daring,
bravely drawing eyes on me.
My siblings and I ran
off the school bus.
My mom sat us down on the couch
and I've seen my mom cry
before, but not like this.
Finding me hidden by my bookshelf
in tears as she decides it's okay
to tell a 12 year old her
grandmother committed suicide,
the grandmother who taught her
how to cook bright yellow eggs,
soaked golden buttery
popcorn just right,
and teach patience enough
to watch any sunset.
She didn't have time
to teach me how to draw
so every letter I write
is straight lines.
A book of pink, yellow, blue, green,
purple, is missing violet, indigo,
chartreuse [inaudible] bumblebee
bright sunshine, gold, butterscotch,
cannery, daffodil, mustard,
lemon [inaudible] blond.
The hair color we shared.
According to my journal,
I'm getting better.
February's over.
The sun's staying out later.
I'm cutting my hair soon.
I'll buy another pen in case
my yellow ever runs out,
and cover pages with
reminders of my happiest days.
I will publish books that open and
spill yellow ink on to your laps,
magazines with foldouts
for every shade imaginable.
And essays written in pink, articles
in purple, poems printed in green,
obituaries written in my blue pen.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges.
Scores. 3.
2. 1. From low to high, 7.3,
7.7, 8.2, 8.4, and an 8.5.
Clap it up for the poet.
Keep that energy going for the
next poet in the first round.
Taya. All the way to
the stage, folks.
All the way to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Taya: So you're about to embark
on your first year at Hogwarts.
I know it's scary.
Starting a new school can be scary,
but fear not, my sweet first year,
as I impart on to you the
knowledge I have gained from years
of house cups and potions
classes that I wish I had had
when I was a young witch.
No standardized test
can measure your magic.
The brightest wizard can fail,
and the dullest can thrive.
No multiple choice mess can
measure just how magical you are.
Your newts and owls
don't define you.
There is nothing uncool
about school spirit.
Deck yourself from head
to toe in house colors.
Scream at the top of your lungs in
the stands for your Quidditch team,
but don't go too hard if they win.
A fire whiskey hangover does
not excuse you from turning
in your potions essay
in the morning.
Remember not to compromise
your beliefs just
because you want to be popular.
As a brave man once said to an even
braver child, "It takes a great deal
of courage to stand up to your
enemies, and an even greater deal
to stand up to your friends."
And remember in 19 years
you aren't going to care
about the professors you
hated or the tests you failed.
You're going to care about
the people you loved,
the memories you made.
For every Dolores Umbridge,
there's a Remus Lupin.
For every Draco Malfoy,
there's a Ron Weasley.
For every Triwizard tragedy,
there is a Yule ball.
And there's a [inaudible]
for any other problem
that might come along the way.
In these dark and troubling
times, we have to remember
that we are magic, and Hogwarts
should feel like our home.
And remember, if all else fails,
Hermione Granger could stay
on her grind and get straight As
during a time of unspeakable magic
that threatened her very existence.
So you can too.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Dramatic.
[Laughs] this is my
biggest fan right there.
Judges. From low to high,
we have scores already.
Here we go.
6.8. 7.5. 8.3.
8.7. And an 8.9.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
[ Applause ]
So if there's something
happening on stage that you enjoy,
please feel free to take to
the interwebs and let the folks
out there who couldn't fit
in this room know about it
because if you haven't noticed
this room's kind of full.
All right?
We're at standing room
only status here.
You can use the hashtag
for the book festival
which is natbookfest.com@atari
-- What is it?
Natbookfest.
Or you can also add at
Split This Rock so we know
that you love what's
happening up here.
And I believe the librarian of
Congress also has her own Twitter.
I know because she just tweeted,
and she put my name in it.
What? Time to die and go to Heaven.
And now for your next poet.
Everyone please start
clapping right now for Anaya.
[ Applause ]
>> Anaya: For Lucas and Latifah,
the two stars that burn themselves
out far before their time.
If tonight is the last
night you plan on breathing,
if the weight of the world is so
heavy on your shoulders you --
The only place you can see to
lay down this burden is a grave.
If you are so tired of this
existence you want to put yourself
in to an eternal rest, I'm sorry.
I cannot make this life
more livable for you.
But before you go, can
I ask you one thing?
When you pick up the pen
to write the suicide note,
write a poem instead.
About all the things you love
and all the things that love you.
Write a poem.
Turn the pain into prose and see
how quickly the end becomes a
new beginning.
Write a poem like your life depends
on it because sometimes it does.
I too have known nights on
bathroom floors with blood
and tears streaming so
quickly I do not know
which one I'll run out of first.
No praying to gods I stopped
believing in a long time ago
that if they were real they
would make the pain go away.
No looking death in the face
and inviting him home for dinner
like a long lost friend I couldn't
wait to get reacquainted with.
But I have also known salvation.
Known that if the words of
your demons can end your life,
then words of hope can save it no
matter how deep a hole you've dug
yourself in to.
Even when holding on to life feels
like grasping air your lungs
can't even keep inside of them,
reach your hands out for a lifeline.
And I'll give you a pen.
And tell you that poetry
is the pathway to healing
that you never saw coming, and
ain't I a testament to that?
Because I am still standing
after depression has
brought me to my knees.
After I have asked God
more times to end my life
than I have thanked
him for giving me it.
And ain't that a blessing?
To survive even when your own
body has tried to kill you?
So hold healing in your hands,
and it gets hard sometimes
because you can't even remember how
to be a person, much less a poet,
but I promise being a poet
isn't always about pretty prose.
Sometimes it is just
about being alive.
Hell, most times it's just about
being alive here in this place.
So I've seen so many
resurrected I almost call it holy.
Call it magic.
So let me spellbind you.
Survival. Put down your razor.
Don't spill blood.
Spill ink.
Write a poem across your wrists and
thighs and show everyone your scars
and story and tell them that
this is what survival looks like.
This is healing.
This is life through language.
And never forget how
hard it was to get here.
To turn your back on your demons.
But if the pen is mightier than
the sword, then it is mightier
than any mental illness
that has tried to kill you.
So tonight so write me a
suicide note, an obituary,
but a period where
there should be a comma.
Write me a survivor story.
And I promise I'll see you tomorrow.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
your score in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have an 8.6, I
have a 9.3, a 9.5, a 9.6, and a 9.8.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
[ Applause ]
A hush comes across the crowd.
Didn't think that was
going to work at all.
But I appreciate how
giving you all are.
You're having a good
time, say, "Yeah."
If you're ready for some more
poetry, say, "Hell yeah."
Coming up next to the stage, please
put your hands together for Asher.
[ Applause ]
>> Asher: I am aching to
lose myself these days.
Fingers curled with a need to touch,
to ease the hurt, writing everything
down like it matters
because maybe it does.
Because maybe my feelings aren't
real if you can't read them because,
like a love too young
to be any less,
maybe a feeling isn't a
feeling if it's not physical.
So make believe that blurry
and scuffing along the blue sky are
scatters and rags of high cloud warm
from the sun, bright and blinding.
Eyes [inaudible] brown are on
the stems of grapes once clear
and lucid now scan
around in watery panic.
This amber melancholy
is smoking and alive.
Hands clasped and teeth
crooked like a zipper,
body warm like an old sweater,
and stained with things
like whiskey colored
regret and drowning in it.
These hands are thin, and
rough, and never meant for this.
Give me a script, a line
to walk, small lights
and murmuring conversations.
Tell me to just keep
breathing because god
of nothing said to
have something to do.
Because we can't hear
all these big plans yet.
I reek of uncertainty,
and half sleep stupor.
So instead of reading
between these blurred lines,
let us measure the margins and
assign meaning in the morning.
Language is a landscape
punctuated by bodies, faces dazed,
tongues slack and mad with heat.
Soil sings for our similes.
So I talk and talk and talk
and never say what I mean.
Unearth my prose just enough
to remember what happened.
Write and write about love
I will not fall in to,
about how I crushed what I could
because it was small and so was I.
About how I wake up and nothing is
beautiful the way I imagined it.
And pretend these words
weigh anything.
Because maybe they do.
Because maybe I don't have to make
these loose lyrics soft enough
to grasp before I litter
them across a page.
Maybe this isn't an ache at
all, and my bones only crack
because they are broken
ballads begging for a new body,
one with palms big enough
to write a biography.
Eyes like bible black
dream catchers.
I am a boy born of hard
lemonade and a Midwest April.
Somewhere there is a
story about kissing once
and leaving in sheets of rain.
And I do not have to
be the one to write it.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have a 7.5,
a 7.9, a 7.9, an 8.1, and an 8.3.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
[ Applause ]
And for your listening
enjoyment we have another poem.
Please put your hands
together for Sophia.
[ Applause ]
>> Sophia: Whole grain toast
slathered in grass fed butter,
the crusts cut off and thrown away.
Dipped in a plate coated
in raw sugar cane.
Her mother brought her munchies
while she taught her baby how
to read.
She pulled books filled with boxes
and CDs from under the table.
She held them with the edges
of her skeletal fingertips
so the records wouldn't wreck.
And they spun with a voice
of wisdom that taught her
to ignore the silent H. On
her first day of kindergarten,
she brought her chapter books
and sounded out sentences
in her head while the teacher
taught the class the alphabet song.
White Wonder Bread coated in
the very last scrape of butter,
she no longer coughs when she bites
in to crusts mixed
with secondhand smoke.
Her lungs were like weeds
from the concrete cracks
of a womb made of nicotine
and whiskey.
She makes herself her meal.
Before cleaning up
familiar carpet stains
by her mother while her baby slept
deeply on the couch to the sounds
of '90s sitcom reruns and
voices of strange men.
She started kindergarten 10 miles
away from her, but learned the song
of beeping metal detectors
instead of the ABCs.
In fifth grade I started
taking care of myself.
My mother let her skeletal
fingertips where some skin
around the bones -- She
entrusted my teachers
to fulfill my thirst for words.
No longer was she busy with
our pocketbooks and ABCs.
She remembered she needed to eat.
By fifth grade she's in foster care.
Her face tells the story of
broken beer bottles slashed
across smooth brown skin, skin
that should have stayed soft
until puberty gave it ridges.
She learned that you can make a
child grow old with suffering,
without giving her the time to age.
She's assigned a book report,
but it's hard to make honor roll
when your mother was gone while
hers was reading her to sleep.
While the books in your
classroom ripped at the hinges --
How are you supposed
to learn to read then?
When the books in her
classroom smelled
of paper printed fresh while
she learned to read "Hamlet"
and "A Midsummer Night's Dream,"
while you sat before a conveyor
belt bringing in new mouths to feed.
It's a decade and some too
late when they finally decide
to open our borders and let
us get to know each other.
And when she gets her first
history report, I wipe a chalkboard
of happy drawings from
an imagination
that wants to replace her memory.
And she copies the
vocab words one by one.
When I ask her to name the
face of 20th century hate,
she is silent with no answer.
When I ask her to name the
faces of peaceful demonstration,
she is silent with no answer.
When I ask her if she
knows her history,
she is silent with no answer.
When I ask her if she
could read the history
that her teachers never taught
her, she is silent with no answer.
So why should I be able to learn
from history and be the future?
So why should she be lost
without words and forced
by the man to stay in the past?
So that you and I, my dear
sister, are both silent.
Waiting for an answer.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Scores up.
3. 2. 1. From low to high, I have a
6.8, a 6.9, a 7.2, a 7.7, and an 8.
Clap it up for the poet, please.
And now for the last poet in
the first round [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 2: Black man ain't found
in history books unless he's broken
or broke or breaking in or broke in.
Black man ain't found in history
books unless he's a puppet painted
as a hero, says to be
successful like him assimilate.
Sell out. Become as white
as the page he's on.
The strong black man ain't
in history books more
than a quota requires because to
document too many black martyrs
would give little black
kids too much strength,
and to document too many living,
breathing blacks will
give them too much hope.
And to document too many black
inventors would give them too
much ambition.
So put a history book in front
of the little black child.
Only show them their ancestors
bloody, broken, raped, and stolen.
Convince them from a young age
submission is in their blood,
that their only chance of getting
rid of it is to bleed it out.
Tell them they're better
off blending in,
that in these books
blacks are never the hero,
seldom the victim,
always the villain.
That if they want to know more
than just how their ancestors
died they have to take it
as a high school elective.
That in these schools their
culture isn't taken seriously.
Neither are their achievements.
But they should still
be happy to learn
about a white man stealing a black
man's land, a black man's wife,
because look at all this
country has done for us.
We should pledge to a flag
that waves our ancestors' blood
in our faces because we don't want
to seem ungrateful for
our freedoms, right?
We should stand and sing
along to the national anthem
because they cut out
the slave verse.
Right? We should support our black
troops fighting for a country
who doesn't even care about them
because at least this way
they're not dying at the hands
of their own country's hate.
Right? At least this way
someone will care enough
to remember them, right?
At least this way they will
finally be labeled as heroes.
Right? At least this way
someone will finally put them
in the history book.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores up in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have an 8.4,
an 8.5, an 8.9, an 8.9 and a 9.3.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
That's the first round.
Let me rephrase that.
That was just the first round.
The hardest part of hosting
is knowing what you're doing.
And two, I'm not allowed
to say anything
about the poems as they go up.
Like if something really affects
me, I have to come up and be like,
"Judges, please tell
me your scores."
Like it didn't just happen.
But we're all here together, and
you all are doing a really good job.
Like because you're all being real
expressive for like every poem,
and like every poem is smacking
me across the face at least once.
If you're having a
good time, say, "Yeah."
If you're having a good
time, make some noise.
[ Shouting ]
It's good.
I hope you're learning
something too.
It's time for the second round.
We're getting right back in it.
We're going right back
up the other order.
If you are enjoying yourselves
and think that poetry is powerful
and has a purpose, please stick here
after the show and come talk to some
of us who do this for a living.
We would love to bring these
programs to your schools.
We would love to tell
you about the events
that we have going
on around the city.
If you have to leave early,
just go to splitthisrock.org.
That's again splitthisrock.org.
And now the next round.
I wanted to give her a breath so
she didn't have to run back up here,
but going in the reverse
order we're starting
with the last poet we just heard.
Please put your hands
together for [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 2: How many daddy's
girls could my daddy turn sour
if my daddy could still
call himself a daddy?
He got six girls, but for as long
as I can remember I was always
daddy's princess and he my king.
My dragon slayer.
My knight in shining armor.
But never put a parent on a pedestal
because kings don't
always do their duty.
Knights aren't always found noble.
And dragons don't always get slain.
And my mama, she say my
daddy always been the same,
but I know he was the remedy
to my tears, not the reason.
He used to let me ride
in his blue Chevy
and teach me how to work the radio.
And we'd go jogging on Sunday
mornings, and I still wonder
if we had been in church
instead of running,
could that have changed this?
Could that have stopped him?
Could that have saved us?
It doesn't matter now.
He used to take me to Maxwell's
Market to get shrimp salad
or couscous, and I still
don't know what couscous is,
but it tastes good.
He used to give me a
small sip of his wine.
And, daddy, you were never drunk
or high, but you hit the highway
like it was a blunt puff, puff.
You passed up your ride
a few too many times,
and I stopped screaming,
"Daddy's home."
Because it was past my bedtime.
But I was still awake because you
didn't slay those scary dragons
under my bed.
So, daddy, tell me how many dragons
could destroy daddy's kingdom
if daddy left his kingdom for dead.
If dragons started having names like
Angela and Shannon, and the monsters
in my nightmares became
his mistresses.
And I stopped worrying
if they were under my bed
because I knew they were in
his, and he had betrayed me.
Us. But I did a good job of never
biting the hand that fed me.
Poison, daddy.
I moved out four years ago.
And I still wonder if you know I'm
angry, if you know your name ain't
on speed dial anymore, if you know
you make bastard sound so heavenly.
Like, yeah, I know you,
but I really don't want to.
My mama ain't leave you
before you had the chance
to break both our hearts.
How you make step daddy
sound like a blessing.
How you make me feel so heavy,
and angry, and hollow, and dark.
Like I got demons, daddy.
Because of you I got
demons, but I don't got you.
And that's one less demon.
And I'm sorry I was
ever a daddy's girl.
And how many daddy's girls
can my daddy turn sour
if my daddy could still
call himself a daddy?
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, we have a 9.1, we
have a 9.3, a 9.4, a 9.5, and a 9.6.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
If you haven't noticed, we've
made it to the second round
where you can talk
about whatever you want.
And they are going to
take that seriously.
All right.
Just keep that energy going.
You all ready for your next poet?
Say, "Poetry."
Please put your hands
together right now for Sophia.
[ Applause ]
>> Sophia: According to WebMD,
it has been scientifically proven
that a hamburger, a bottle of
vodka, a pill from your pharmacist,
a teacher with an attached metal
detector, computer screen, a knife,
and even your very own sex
organs have the undeniable power
to take your life, and
all in the exact same way.
So I guess I didn't believe in
internet science until I started
to go through the bold black print
on the medical records
in my file cabinet.
Dominant genes cross dominant genes.
I was destined to be the
poster child for either AA,
the [inaudible] Center, or "My
Strange Addiction," and with a flip
of the dice it would be determined
that bathroom scale
would become [inaudible].
The military diet would
become the gospel.
Three days devoted to starvation,
one for the father, one for the son,
and the last for the holy spirit.
I suppose I stopped believing
in God when I begged him
to give me the strength to starve,
and he gave me weakness in return.
When I assumed he gave me my life
to Earth so my body could eat itself
from the inside out like black
crows feeding on dying flesh.
As a child, they taught me in
Catholic school that it was a sin
to commit suicide, but
how could I not believe
that it wasn't God's purpose, my
life's purpose, to make my body
so small it would evaporate
in to thin air?
That happiness could -- would come
when I could walk in to a room
and sugar quietly on my own while
the rest of the world felt the kind
of warmth that makes your eyes
close slowly on their own.
My body unable to creek the
most ancient floorboard,
I would stop taking up so much
space, I would stop apologizing
for being alive because
now I was just a corpse.
When the human body starves,
all it can think about is food.
When all it can think about is
food, the sadness goes away.
When the sadness goes away,
the dopamine does too.
And when feeling is gone,
your addiction has
reduced you to a vegetable.
Feelingless corpse dying slowly
with no water to help it grow.
Recovery brought back feeling.
And while I don't like to be
rained on, I now knew I needed it
to grow root strong,
deep in to the soil,
find water for my deserted
body to feed my mind.
Learn slowly that trees
can grow amongst fungus.
Feeling dread and sorrow
and worry and pain,
I could genetically engineer my
own body, step out of my coma,
to end generations of pain
when at birth I was
declared to be just a corpse.
So before you ask an addict
how it feels to be addicted,
before you ask a dying
girl how it feels to starve
and blame fat shaming
or diet culture,
ask them first how it feels
to feel nothing at all.
Ask her first if the hunger
pains have numbed her own.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have a 7.3,
a 7.6, a 7.9, an 8.7, and an 8.7.
Clap it up for the poet.
And keep that energy
going for the next poet.
Asher.
[ Applause ]
>> Asher: When I was seven,
like many other children,
I raced rain drops down
the chilled surface
of my mother's backseat car window.
Like other children, my tummy turned
when the moon's seemingly
mournful gaze managed to filter
in through treetops no matter
how many corners we turned.
I was convinced it was following me.
I remember my mother comparing my
body to that of rain smooth stone,
my thoughts the weather
above the ocean.
She tells me my storms
are unpredictable,
but she's always just
telling me things.
Like get your fingers
off the window.
You're going to leave
prints on them.
And I don't know.
It was just saying that even
when I didn't ask or care.
Making three words feel like four.
A flaky pie crust of
my mind circuits,
of static and licked batteries.
Before I was 11 and learned the
water cycle in [inaudible] narrow,
always too bright, carpet never
cleaned classroom, I asked my mother
where my tears went in the night.
Remained stoic when she
replied, "I don't know."
Asked my dreams instead.
While she drew bath
water, I drew conclusions.
Decided I could still see
things with my eyes closed.
Decided I could crush
rules under tons of air,
and saw that there were
records of the tides here,
and rivers were the same
lukewarm blue of my bed sheets.
Thunder promised, but
didn't deliver last night.
She's like a forlorn
and bewildered mommy.
I watch the wind whip the
[inaudible] scrutinize the clouds
looming like a funeral where
you aren't really sure who died.
A mammoth hook of muddy water,
a can opener to the
[inaudible] of [inaudible] waves.
I thought I knew.
The day we ran out of hot water,
like we were always
running out of things.
Like time, and what to
say, and yellow light.
All the things she doesn't
know, they're coursing
through carrot peels in my sink,
condemned to trickle in to sludge
and sand before reaching the ocean.
We are both thirsty,
but it is careless
or cruelty watering the
street as well as the lawn.
So the facts go damp
around their borders.
I creep down the hall
in to the closet
where at the back the walls still
smell of hair oil and oranges.
Mama, the moon is staring at me.
Mama, it's raining.
And, mama, I don't know
where the river is.
I am a mess of good
intentions gone wrong.
I strike a match on
myself to keep others warm,
but the whole world is on fire.
And I'm trying so hard to put it out
that the dam breaks and the waters
of my soggy sorrow pour
free, and I am sorry.
So very, very sorry.
And I will drown everyone
to prove it.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges, from low
to high I have an 8.2, an 8.3,
an 8.5, an 8.5, and a 9.4.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
I just want to do this again
because these folks have been coming
up like racers where
they tag each other out.
What is that called?
Relay racers.
You're welcome.
And doing an amazing job, I think.
I don't speak the language,
but they look
like they're doing
it very, very well.
Can we please clap one more
time for our interpreters?
[ Applause ]
Because the world is better
when everybody has access.
Coming up next, please put
your hands together for Anaya.
[ Applause ]
>> Anaya: Just real
quick trigger warning
for sexual assault
and sexual violence.
When my little brother asks me,
all of his eight year
old body tremoring,
if monsters are real,
I want to lie to him.
Tell him that they aren't.
That they are all fog
figments of fear
that only exist in his nightmares.
All imagination.
That he has nothing to worry about.
And I know it sounds deceiving,
but if given the choice,
I would have chosen the ignorance.
The innocence.
But sometimes we don't have
[inaudible] option, and the things
that happen to us, and the
lessons we learn far too quickly,
I have known monsters of men.
One who showed their things in the
prettiest of smiles and then draw me
in just close enough to
take a bite out of me.
And no matter how many times my
fists have made blow with his belly,
he still has not regurgitated
the piece of me he swallowed,
and I have grown far too fired
up asking to have it back.
Because men like him have always
just taken what they wanted no
matter how many noes they have
had to swallow in the process
or how much of his skin I have left
beneath my nails from the fight,
and it be the only
piece of me I have left.
Along with the ache in
my chest mourning my soul
and innocence and the memories.
Like the grasp of his fist or the
crack in my back or the feeling
of the wall he pushed me against
while he tried to push in to me
or the sting of his,
"Don't tell nobody.
Won't nobody believe you anyways."
And he was right.
When I accused my best
friend of sexual assault,
everyone accused me of falsifying.
Lying. Called me whore.
But called him confused boy
caught up in his feelings.
I called him monster.
And they asked me what I
did to make him that way.
What a girl has to do to
cause someone so close to her
to commit such unspeakable acts.
And maybe that's why they stay
silent through all of this.
Through the bleeding.
And the broken.
While I tended to my wounds and
he went off to find the next girl
who he will hold just as tightly as
he did me and call her best friend.
And little sister.
And his favorite girl.
And bearer of faults when he makes a
mistake for the third time at home.
He can't wait to force
himself in to a body.
himself in to a girl.
He will wrongfully [inaudible]
a passage in to woman
in everything but victim.
Everything but catastrophe
he created.
Like he ain't the scariest
kind of creature.
The one who hides in plain sight.
So when my little brother
asks me if monsters are real,
I will scowl and tell him, "Yes."
But that the deadliest kind
don't live underneath your bed.
No. They lay beside you in it.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges, scores.
3, 2, 1. From low to high, I have an
8.6, a 9.1, a 9.2, a 9.2, and a 10.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
Coming up next, keep that
energy going for your next poet.
Taya.
[ Applause ]
>> Taya: There are
remnants of scars on my back
from where his ancestors whipped
mine, and he likes to claw at them.
When we kissed, it felt like a
1960s black and white "I Dream
of Jeanie" fantasy when in reality I
was the genie from "Aladdin" waiting
to be set free, and black and
white was all he could ever see.
He speaks like a slave master
yet jumps down my throat
when I accuse him of
mirroring his ancestors.
And I see them in the arch of his
brow and underscoring his jaw.
But that kiss.
That kiss is a leash
woven of, "Let me fix him.
I can fix him.
Please let me fix him.
Let me teach him to paint
with the colors of the wind
like a Disney sanitized Pocahontas."
Never mind what happened
to the real Pocahontas.
Let me shield his body from your
bullets, blanketing his with mine
like that weird scene in
the climax of "Pocahontas."
Now we're back to that
Pocahontas metaphor,
and I am back to defending
a racist who wants
to colonize the space
between my thighs.
How am I supposed to learn to
stand strong when I have spent
so much time kneeling
for my oppressor?
Every so often he loosens his grip
on the leash, lets it go as far
as it can stretch,
and then whips it back
like I am a bitch who might bite.
With affirmations of,
"You look nice today.
You write so well.
Girl, that ass, though."
Heel, girl.
Sit. Stay.
He teases me with treats
so I will do a trick,
and then does not give me one.
I am like a frog in a pot, and he
is a mad scientist waiting to turn
up the heat and boil me alive.
Do you know how it feels to
be like Wonder Woman going
to the front lines to
fight only to find he was
on the other side the whole
time possessed by Ares?
Do you know how it feels to realize
women of color are Amazon warriors?
And racist white men
do not deserve us.
So from here on out, I will
be putting Elise Estrada
on all misogynistic cans of Miracle
Whip who are hell bent on turning me
into a palatable milk chocolate
to mix in to their vanilla,
to colonize, to fetishize.
And I encourage you to join me and
join my nation of carefree women
of color who are strong enough to
make this nation bend to their will
and to pull themselves off that
leash and love themselves first.
We are not exotic spices
to be yanked off of vines,
put in jars, and kept on shelves.
And we are not dogs to be
kept in cages when we act up.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores up in 3, 2, 1.
From low to high, I have a 7.8, a --
[ Shouting ]
You good? 7.9.
8.5. 8.9. And a 9.2.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
We have two more poets
before this is over.
Are you ready?
Make some noise.
Coming up next, Catherine.
Keep clapping.
[ Applause ]
>> Catherine: I hope this is on.
I hope you can hear this.
You better hear this.
You ask me to write a poem
I have already written.
I can't read the news anymore.
Literally.
My eyes blur every headline.
The news of course being the
fact that Nazis are back.
Literal, actual Nazis.
And the news that censored
is a child rapist.
Foreign leaders making headlines in
our own country more than their own.
CNN anchors creating
false news as facts,
and Fox news cameramen
paid to reshoot.
"Washington Post" today posts
anything other than Washington.
Can we just recount this?
Start the timer over?
Let's go back to before November
before we had a censored businessman
who has claimed bankruptcy six
times and in no time at all shut
down the investigation on
the Flint water crisis?
Poisoning my body by sponsoring
an anti-choice bill in a room full
of men that's mandating
mother, censored.
Ban Muslim countries as if religion
has a physical location and as
if religion is the thing to
fear here, not that racist
in an orange color stained suit.
How did we mess up this bad here
in an inauguration speech written
to include the slogan for the KKK?
A vice who believes in
electrocuting queer teens.
Unrelated, but checking the
box for some election was hard.
Do you support accidental nuclear
war or purposeful genocide?
Great news.
One box, not to name any
boxes by names, had both.
And a lot of other stuff.
I used to build box forts as a
child, but thankfully I grew up
and didn't move on
to building walls.
I'm trying to tear them down, but
lately I've been too busy, I guess,
just surviving on cardboard I
guess, writing any news I can.
If someone's 140 characters
can ignite the whitest fire
in a neo Nazi's heart, I guess
mine should be able to smother it.
Racial violence is rude and
terrible [inaudible] good blood
on tax payer lawns.
America must stop this.
Bad. My fingers are moving too fast.
I lose track.
Typing class in elementary
taught me the base keys.
A. S. D. F. J. K. L. Semicolon.
I'm thinking with all the education
cuts all someone's learning is A, M,
E, R, I, K, K, K. I'm not
as informed as I need to be,
trying to keep up, but the Fox
news commercials look so invited.
Yeah. I want to Sham Wow.
Sop up the blood on the
streets they're trying to blame
on whatever minority
it is this week.
Two months ago I wrote a poem.
I've kind of given up rewriting it
because we don't need a new start.
We need a revolution.
Black lives matter.
The first pride was a riot.
Keep abortion legal.
Feminism means nothing if
it is not intersectional.
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges,
scores in 3, 2, 1.
From low to high, I have an 8.4,
a 9.1, a 9.2, a 9.3, and a 10.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
You all ready for the last poem?
Say, "Yeah."
Coming up next to the stage, please
put your hands together for Maya.
[ Applause ]
>> Maya: To every white
person who is surprised
that racism still exists in
2017, did you think it died just
because we stopped
calling it a plantation?
Is it because the owners look
more like Wall Street suit
and tie stockbrokers
trading children
from the city's poorest
schools for jail cells?
Do you think it died just because
the master has a badge now?
Why do you care so much that
he replaced his whip with a gun
when his target was
always a black body?
Did you hope his shackles
wouldn't someday imprison your son?
Or were you surprised
that some babies come
in to this world rope already
tied tight around their necks?
Did you find yourself at the
mercy of another headline hoping
that your son's name wouldn't
be mentioned next to Trayvon's
or Tamir's or [inaudible]
or Philando's?
Did you ever consider why after each
of those names the next
one never surprised you?
Is it because your Facebook feed
can afford to be all cute kittens
and pumpkin spice lattes?
Did you not see the videos of black
and brown children's bodies traded
as trauma stories on white
people's Facebook pages
to prove how woke you are?
To prove how open your eyes are
because your eyes can afford
to be both blinking and alive?
To prove that your heart
can be both beating
and be not asking to
get shot by a cop?
Does it surprise you that black and
brown children raised under ball
and chain, clad in orange
jumpsuit, got paid nothing
to make your car's license plates?
To sew the stars on
your country's freedom?
Did it surprise you when Heather
died because you thought people
who looked like you are bulletproof?
Or because you thought you'd
never have to find out.
Does it surprise --
Will it surprise you
when police rob another
child of his life?
Use his skin color to determine
the quality of his education?
The nutrition of his food?
Or will it only surprise you when
another army of white nationalists
with torch and swastika flag
march through the streets?
You say you don't see color.
So why is your Facebook page awfully
active when a white ally dies
for doing the right thing?
But silent when a person
of color dies for existing?
You say you can't believe
how bad hate is in 2017,
but how many more bones
do you need to stand
on before you realize your
country was built on a graveyard?
How many more souls have
to lose their bodies before you stop
being surprised and start listening?
Have you considered how much more
of your surprise this
world can tolerate?
How many more headlines will it
take before you stop being surprised
that racism still exists?
And start being angry?
[ Applause ]
>> Joseph Green: Judges, scores up.
3. 2. 1. From low to high, I
have an 8.5, I have an 8.8,
an 8.9, a 9.2, and a 9.9.
Clap it up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
You can't say I didn't tell you.
May I have every poet that touched
the stage on the stage right now,
please, while we are
tabulating the scores?
Can we give them the round of
applause that they deserve?
[ Applause ]
Can you put numbers besides first,
second, and third real quick?
[ Applause ]
All right.
So -- Because we are about to go
over time if we have not already.
I just want to say a couple things.
One, on behalf of Split This
Rock, we are so honored to be able
to come and hold this space.
Thank you to the Library
of Congress.
Thank you to the people at
the National Book Festival
for making this possible.
I would like to say that this
is just an ordinary thing,
but we know that some of the words
that get said here are inflammatory.
Or dangerous.
But true. Right?
And until we live in a world
where we can just tell the truth
and it doesn't have to be a
special occasion, we're still going
to have these poetry readings
here, there, and everywhere
because these young people
deserve, demand, have earned,
will take the microphone as needed.
On behalf of Split This Rock
and the Library of Congress,
I want to thank our esteemed judges.
Thank you so very much for
taking the time to be here.
Some powerful and amazing people.
I would also like to thank the
National Endowment of the Arts.
Yes. And I would also like to
ask you to keep fighting for it.
And now since we had these judges
give numbers to score these poems,
I'm going to tell you who
is third, second, and first.
Knowing full well that we all won.
Yay. The point is not the point.
There we go.
In third place, coming from --
In third place, from
Minnesota, Catherine.
[ Applause ]
In second place, from
Baton Rouge [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
Can I get a drum roll?
And in first place, from
Washington, D.C., Anaya Smith.
[ Applause ]
Thank you all for coming.
Please if they are open to it, come
and say hello to one of the poets.
Give them a high five.
Please ask before you hug.
But yeah. Come and talk to us.
If you want to know more about Split
This Rock, Library of Congress,
all that jazz, we will be up here
with business cards and love.
And there's a table in the back
about all things Split This Rock
where Sue is waving
her hand right now.
Have a good night, and
support our local art.
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.